the chicago bears announced what was
widely expected both ryan pace the gm
and matt nagy will be back as head coach
next year my position was very simple
fire both or fire neither and if you
fire both you better fire ted phillips
as well because that guy's been there 21
years hiring general managers and
coaches who've been getting fired
because they haven't gotten it done so i
think they made the right decision under
the circumstances stay the course
they've been to the playoffs two out of
the last three years they got to fix the
quarterback position if it's a disaster
next year yeah everybody gets fired but
the next time everybody gets fired
everybody needs to include the president
of the team who avoids accountability
we've talked about these jobs these are
the jack easter bee jobs the people who
have their their spoon in the stew but
if the stew ends up being rancid they
never are asked to turn in their apron
and mike they've made it clear by saying
today that we are not giving these guys
contract extensions that they are
absolutely on the hot seat and they need
to take another step now what that other
step is
we don't know whether that means winning
a playoff game or getting to the
championship game or getting the super
bowl we don't know what that next step
is but pace will be in hit the final
year of his deal and naggy has two years
left on his deal so these guys are
absolutely on the hot seat going in this
year they're going to have to answer
that quarterback question and answer it
in a hurry if they're going to keep
their jobs beyond this season
let me make one other point real quick i
know we have to go we've got football
pod in america coming up and as usual it
chews up about half of the show the
vikings still don't know what's
happening with offensive coordinator
gary kubiak they better figure that out
because that's not going to be an easy
job to fill because there's a hot seat
in minnesota for 2021 it reminds me of
coaches in the past like like a lovey
smith when he was in chicago and he was
on the hot seat it's hard to hire an
offensive coordinator when that guy
knows that everyone's job is riding on
his performance in his first year so
they better figure this out and i've
heard that gary kubiak's trying to
position his son clint to take over
whatever they're doing they better
figure it out because it's going to be
hard to find anybody maybe they have to
give it to clint because everybody else
will say no thank you i don't want to be
the guy who has to save everyone's job
by fixing kirk cousins in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports